Here are the three properties again that we've been discussing, the Product
Property, the Quotient Property, and the Power Property. Many logarithmic
expressions can be rewritten or expanded or condensed using these properties.
First, let's think about what it means to expand a logarithmic expression. That
basically means that we're going to break down something that looks complicated
into smaller pieces. This logarithmic equation is a great one to work with for
doing this. We have log base 3 of 6x squared y cubed. Let's break it down, we
can expand this to log base 3 of 6 plus log base 3 of x squared plus log base 3
of y cubed. Which property that you've learned about allowed us to do this
expansion? Was it the product property, the log of the product is equal to the
sum of the logs? Was it the quotient property, the log of the quotient is equal
to the difference of logs? Or was it the power property, the log of something
raised to a power is equal to the power times just the log?